37 % de la surface agricole utile cela
va être complété d'ailleurs dès les
prochaines semaines puisque au mois de
juin nous aurons les résultats de toutes
les analyses faites en 2010 est donc ça
va venir compléter les mesures et cette
cartographie sera elle évoluera dans le
dans le temps elle a pour vocation
d'être d'être complété et d'ailleurs dès
l'année prochaine
moi ce que je souhaite c'est qu'on est
encore un bond significatif et que l'on
dépasse la moitié de cette surface
agricole utile la ministre des autres
maire annick girardin a fixé un objectif
c'est de parvenir à compléter l'ensemble
de la surface agricole utile sans doute
dans les deux à trois ans c'est une
première au public on a toujours demandé
une cartographie de la réalité de
l'empoisonnement ils ont toujours donné
une cartographie de la potentialité de
raisonnement ce que veut dire il y avait
de la banane c'est pollué et puis on
permet aux agriculteurs de faire
quelques et analystes il y avait eu une
analyse de faits et puis on a arrêté
l'analyse analyse est gratuite
donc vous comprenez que ce ça a été
aussi et donc pour le moment on a une
cartographie eu trait est complète et
alors je l'avais fait aux marques et aux
puf et parce qu'il était persuadé
d'avoir une cartographie qu'ils allaient
publier qui étais tu dis tu n'es pas de
cartographie mais je le buffet est là
maintenant ils disent qu'ils vont
compléter appelé mais complété comment
compléter au bon vouloir des
propriétaires qui vont demander les
niveaux là ils vont peut-être pas payer
vont reprendre la gratuité mais c'est à
la demande des propriétaires maintenant
enfin il faut faire il faut faire des
analyses
systématique et pas seulement sur le s à
eux de s a eu ses surfaces agricoles
utilisées faut le faire aussi sur les
terrains en friche et parce que ce sont
ces terrains qui sont les plus
susceptibles de ne pas être pollué
puisqu'il y avec bennati s'est de cette
carte
ça nous permet de savoir jeu avec des
bassins versants
mais pour moi c'est pas il n'y a pas
d'autre aujourd'hui à 103% les coptes
qui sont pollués et ce qui est important
de savoir c'est que les gens s'ils
veulent une garantie d'avoir de bons
produits qui ne sont pas pour les
banques lors de faire confiance au
cirque il faut mène au provisionnel
beaucoup satisfait de la cartographie
qui a été non pas 12 34% de deux
terrains identifiés à mon avis il faut
complet il faut plus de compliments à
mon avis ça n'en fait pas vraiment la
situation